[Música]
y hoy en revista de prensa nos acompaña
como siempre nuestra compañera Rosa
Pérez más déu Rosa bienvenida cómo está
Buenos días María Clara Bien y tú muy
bien gracias entonces yo le propongo que
hoy empecemos con una pregunta que se
están haciendo varios periodistas y
varias personas alrededor del mundo y es
Qué países van a enviar tanques de
guerra pesados a Ucrania y se lo
pregunto porque precisamente del
periódico lemont de Francia se está
haciendo esta cuestión exactamente
empezando respondiendo no a esta
pregunta de Finalmente Cuáles van a ser
los países occidentales que van a mandar
tanques pesados a Ucrania empezamos por
Alemania que ha sido el país que ha
protagonizado el debate en las últimas
semanas no porque tal y como expresó
ayer mismo el canciller Alemán Olaf
shorts Alemania quiere hacer lo
necesario para apoyar a Ucrania Pero
quiere evitar una escalada del conflicto
que desencadene en una guerra de Rusia
contra la otan finalmente ayer miércoles
Alemania se decidió a mandar 14 tanques
leopardos y autorizó a otros países a
mandar algunos de los leopard que tienen
a sus respectivos ejércitos una decisión
que habría estado motivada por un por un
lado por la intensificación de los
ataques rusos en zonas civiles por otro
lado también porque cada vez la
perspectiva de una guerra larga es más
clara y el envío de tanques no siempre
había sido una opción considerada de
largo plazo y por otro lado también
porque Estados Unidos se ha decidido
también a mandar sus propios tanques
particularmente estamos hablando de 31
tanques a Abraham luego tenemos los
tanques de Países Bajos Que de momento
ha anunciado 18 leopards Noruega y
España también se han declarado
dispuestos a mandar algunos de sus
blindados y Londres ya anunció el 14 de
enero que mandaría 14 de sus tanques
Challenger mientras que Francia estudia
en estos momentos la posibilidad de
mandar algunos de sus leclerc pero los
los mandos del ejército de momento se
oponen a esta decisión argumentando que
ya tienen pocos blindados para
entrenarse en estos momentos como para
cederlos a Ucrania bueno Rosa y Tengo
una pregunta para que usted nos explique
y es estos tanques la característica es
que son blindados y son una ofensiva
mayor pero en el campo de batalla
realmente qué tan determinantes pueden
ser según el secretario general de la
otan hablamos
estos tanques pueden ayudar a Ucrania a
ganar la guerra eso sí no en el número
que están a previstos actualmente no y
es que según calcula el New York Times
ahora mismo los países occidentales
miembros de la otan se han comprometido
a mandar a Ucrania 105 de estos ataques
pesados mientras que Ucrania considera
que necesitaría unos 300 para expulsar a
los rusos de su territorio por otro lado
también Como comentábamos hay que tener
en cuenta la sobre Cuándo van a llegar
exactamente estos tanques no como bien
comentabas antes a María Clara está
previsto que Alemania los mande en marzo
según anunció el ministro de defensa de
Alemania mientras que en el caso de
Estados Unidos la incógnita todavía es
más amplia y tal y como señala este
artículo una de las características del
envío de armamento occidental a Ucrania
es que se ha mantenido en secreto hasta
el momento desde el inicio del conflicto
de hecho las vías por las que llegan
estos armamentos para que Rusia no los
sabotea así que bueno iremos viendo al
medida que avancen los meses cambiemos
ahora de tema y vamos a India porque la
bbc hizo un documental que se llama la
cuestión modi en la que se hace varias
preguntas sobre el Primer Ministro
narendra modi de qué se trata Y por qué
ha sido censurado bien como bien decías
es un documental de la bbc de dos
episodios de momentos emitió en la
primero y aborda este documental el rol
del actual Primer Ministro narendra modi
él no sea llamados disturbios de guyarat
unos actos de violencia considerados el
episodio de violencia religiosa más
crudo desde que India se independizó en
1947 y en ese momento
era ministro principal no del estado de
guyarat y se considera que su actuación
digamos permitió una impunidad total a
la hora de que se digamos desencadenara
este crudo episodio de violencia
hablamos concretamente de que se
incendió un tren en el que viajaban
pelegrinos hindús a raíz de ese incendio
murieron 59 personas se acusó a personas
musulmanas de provocar este incendio lo
que desencadenó en una ola de ataques
contra la comunidad musulmana acabaron
muriendo más de un millar de personas
particularmente
790 musulmanes y 254 hindús según la
revista Time que estamos viendo en ese
momento y el documental tal y como
señala este esta revista muestra con
imágenes crudas y escalofriantes como la
policía se mantuvo al margen mientras
grupos hindús atacan a musulmanes en
todo el estado y si bien modi es acusado
de racismo Él y su partido este
documental muestra particularmente una
documento del ministro de Exteriores
británicos en que se considera
directamente responsable del clima de
impunidad que permitió la esclada de
violencia un escenario que tenía todas
las características de una limpieza
étnica Viena para terminar María Clara
las autoridades indias están intentando
censurar este documental en la India
Precisamente lo han pedido así a YouTube
y a Twitter de momento están
respondiendo estas plataformas
censurando tuits o clips no que muestren
parte del documental por lo que se está
criticando tanto sobre todo a elon musk
no que se abanderó de la de una supuesta
libertad de expresión total a la hora de
adquirir Twitter Gracias Rosa por todo
este reporte que nos trae y nosotros
continuamos con más en directo América